hola estamos aquí con ben quien es quien
crea muchos de los ejercicios de khan
academy o las cosas
ok este ahora mira estamos trabajando en
el teorema fundamental de la aritmética
eso es emocionante muy emocionante
qué maravilla a ver entonces vamos
viendo poco a poco de qué se trata el se
trata de factorizar en primos 9
exactamente y la idea de la
factorización en primos más o menos es
que un número lo podemos expresar como
producto como la multiplicación de
números primos verdad por ahí
exactamente cualquier número más grande
que uno a aclaró y éste creo que tú me
comentabas que eso es único sólo hay una
forma de hacerlo exactamente por eso es
un teorema muy importante que padre
haber bueno vamos a tratar de
solucionarlo entonces lo que yo veo aquí
dice que encuentra la factorización de
primos este en este caso es del 18
verdad
dice que aclaró que tengo que usar las
flechas para los exponentes entonces a
ver vamos a recordar tantito aunque
claro hemos hecho muchísimo
vídeos de exponentes que uno podría
consultar la idea de un exponente es que
tengo una base sí claro y esa base es
importante sal pero además tenemos un
exponente que nos dice el exponente
cuántas veces multiplico ese número por
sí mismo por ejemplo ahorita la
selección es dos veces y claro si yo
multiplico dos veces el 2
ese es 4 y distribución multiplicada
tres veces por sí mismo pues eso 8 y en
fin digo esa es la idea de las de los
exponentes es totalmente sal de hecho lo
que podemos hacer es hacer un árbol de
descomposición de primos del número 18
muy bien hoy pero también veo que en la
programación que hiciste este tiene
pistas verdad es precisamente parece si
vamos revisando las pistas que nos vas a
proporcionar salen entonces a ver este
me tengo que ir para abajo a ver éste
ayúdame tantito en clara gracias grabar
aquí nos podemos bajar vamos a ver una
pista
entonces dice podemos utilizar un árbol
de factores para descomponer el 18 en
sus factores primos cuando los números
primeros divide al 18
amira muy bien es que claro el 18 como
spark sonaba que tenía que salir el 2 no
es exactamente entonces dos veces 9 es
18 muy bien perfecto por lo tanto
ponemos un 2 y si te das cuenta el 9 el
9 no es un número par te das cuenta
saben a tiene razón a lo que tú te
refieres es que en este caso nada más
vamos a tener un 2
eso ya lo tenemos 2 por 9 y como 9 no es
pan no aparecerá más otra vez el 2
perfecto por lo tanto aquí tenemos 3 12
cuando aparece si quitamos no ponemos
muy bien y ahora tenemos el 9 de acuerdo
a mí el 9 quienes son los factores claro
vamos a ver las pistas pero se me antoja
que el 33 por 39 el agro eso dicen tus
pistas hay que tener cuidado recuerda
que el 9 es un número impar pero no es
un número primo de hecho no está aquí
vamos a ver qué me dice mi siguiente
pista
efectivamente hasta el 2 que ya
conocíamos agresso por 3 entonces 18 es
dos por tres por tres exacto muy bien
entonces estamos 23 estas acuerdos a
nuestras de juego claro claro mundiales
si no son ni 83 entonces si mira ya nos
muestra que dos por nueve que es dos por
tres por tres más bien que es lo mismo
que dos por nueve es 18 - evento a ver
pero veamos una pista no terminemos de
analizar la de revisar las pistas a mira
nos dice que el 3 es primo y entonces ya
terminamos muy bien muy leo que suena a
que podemos ya comprobar la respuesta a
ver vamos a ver qué pasa
muy bien perfecto muy bien nosotros por
favor ven
a mira ahora salió el 22 muy bien ese es
un número interesante entonces a mí se
me antoja que bueno el 22 es para mí
tenemos que empezar con un 2 pero por
qué no vamos revisando las las pistas a
veces es bueno revisar las pistas para
darte una idea de qué es lo que está
pasando perfecto entonces aquí nos dice
que podemos crear el árbol de factores
que es lo que estamos haciendo hoy esta
primer pregunta es como para invitar a
la gente a reflexionar verdad
exactamente muy bien eventos vamos a la
sal de los números primos dividida el 22
muy bien vamos a ver entonces
efectivamente lo que esperábamos tú y yo
ya apareció el 2 y ahora dos veces 11 es
22 muy bien vamos a ponerlo en 12
perfecto
oye pero bien mira lo que observo es que
en la lista de los primos
ahí está el 11 entonces yo creo que ya
terminamos pero pero continuemos viendo
las pistas tienes toda la razón vamos a
ver las demás pistas pero aquí está el
11 por tanto como claro si es primo no
vamos a necesitarlo
y parece que sí funciona el teorema
fundamental
vamos a ponerle el 11/1/11 muy bien
perfecto 322 perfecto a ver vamos a
comprobar la respuesta bien eso de lujo
y somos bueno sé muy bien hoy este que
te pasa hacemos uno más me parece
perfecto perfecto ahora nos toca el 14 1
y el 14 ahora en el 14 por ejemplo bueno
se ve a leguas que no es no es primo
porque es park y obviamente no está en
nuestra lista
entonces yo sé bueno ya ya sabemos que
el 2 es factor de 14 exactamente de
hecho sería muy bueno que tú deseas en
tu cuaderno utilizando un árbol de
factorización tienes toda la razón no
habíamos mencionado esto hay que hacerlo
en un cuaderno hay que hacer los
cálculos con un lápiz y un papel tienes
razón y si te atrás podemos ver una
pista a ver claro no sé vamos a ver la
ves me parece una buena idea otra vez
aquí nos invitan a reflexionar muy bien
ven qué bueno que pusiste eso
efectivamente dos por 714 oye pero pero
está trabajando estar el 2 pero yo creo
que el 7 ya terminamos nos vamos a 7
es un número primo entonces son 27 pero
vamos a terminar de ver las pistas en el
suelo y vamos a ver qué me dice
perspectiva me escribo y ya terminamos
de factorizar comprobemos de lujo
estábamos bien oye pues muchas gracias
muchas gracias a él por invitarme a
nuevos otro día hasta luego